what's up everyone welcome back for
another Comic-Con interview with the
cast of Paper Girls you are all
incredible everybody out there trust me
when I tell you you are going to want to
get to know every single individual at
this table right now and speaking of
that I have a group question for you so
one of my favorite things to do is look
at everyone's IMDb trivia page and learn
like random fun facts about them and I
have a feeling everyone out there is
going to want to know that about you so
if you could add one really silly fact
about yourself to that page what would
it be I have a greeting card collection
oh yeah and she has it hung up on her
wall I collect them everywhere I go I
have a ton from Chicago they have really
good greeting cards in Chicago if
anyone's looking for one I love that I
drink a lot of chocolate milk
foreign
Cameron do you have one I collect Disney
princess mugs oh you guys are good
collectors yeah and pins like but not
Disney princess pins I just collect pins
in general
I'm trying to think of something I
collect I I uh
six I have uh sticks we we keep sticks
in the house call them the hidden sticks
so we have we have some long ones some
short ones they're all around the house
okay and rocks hidden rocks all good
collections right there I have a feeling
the pin collection is going to serve you
well at Comic-Con because there's a lot
of good pins to buy out there I love
pins all right let us talk about you all
as individuals now first Riley for you I
know altered carbon was the first really
big gig you booked is there anything
about your experience working on that
show that served you well on paper girl
something that makes you think if I
didn't have that experience there I
wouldn't be able to do this here well I
have to say that altered carbon was
definitely a very intense show to start
off with and it was a nice introduction
to like the very high stake scenes that
we do in paper girls as well as the
Sci-Fi aspect of it as well how about
the idea of this being your first time
in a lead role on a show is there
anything that surprised you what it
means to be that that kind of
involvement on a particular show well I
knew that the comic books had meant it
means a lot to a lot of people and I
feel so privileged to be a part of it
and as a fan of the comic books myself I
feel like the fans will be satisfied as
well as pleasantly surprised and I hope
that you guys love it alright so Athena
for you I was busy doing my research and
I found a whole bunch of Matilda Clips
yeah incredible they're incredible was
it being on stage the original goal or
did you always know you wanted to be a
Screen Actor as well well I actually
started out on film
um I loved that introduction I had done
some theater before I started working
professionally
um but I just always wanted to be
performing and no matter really what
medium it was I've always loved drawing
and you know singing and dancing and
just being creative in some respect uh
and then Matilda was a really special
experience because I was one of four I
shared that role with three other girls
girls and I feel very comfortable in a
quartet now and I'm just I think I feel
very at home now with these four girls
getting back to that
um kind of beginning I love that so much
so is there anything about acting for
this stage that you find influencing
your work acting for the camera
something that proved to be helpful that
maybe you didn't expect well on stage
you always have a live audience
obviously and
um learning to perform in front of a
live audience is something that kind of
can translate to to anyone and it kind
of teaches you how to react to people
um you you feed off of whoever's in the
room and the energy and whoever whoever
you're with so these girls definitely
gave me a lot to work off of they're all
very incredibly talented and I think
that kind of just you know can prepare
me for anything I'm gonna do in the
future okay I'm gonna break up my path
going down the line here and pose a
question to all four of you that kind of
pertains to that but I always love
asking people about the value of working
with a really good scene partner so can
you each give me an example of a Time on
set where you wouldn't have been able to
do something yourself if one of your
co-stars wasn't there for you being the
scene partner you needed in the moment I
would say in the car because there we
had some car scenes and I feel like we
all really thrived off of each other in
those scenes because it would have been
weird if just one of us was like
screaming hysterical and all the rest
were like dead faced so it was really
amazing to like feed off of these guys
because it I feel like it just made the
scene so much better
yeah I totally agree with Cameron I
think the scenes where there's some
tension just kind of working off each
other's tension that that's these guys
just rocked it and it it really does
give you something to hit back with you
know something to play off of
there's this one scene that I can't say
very much about but it was with Sophia
and it is an incredible scene that you
guys are gonna love when you see it
um but she just does an absolutely
phenomenal job in it and it was a
pleasure to work off of you I don't know
if you know what scene I'm talking about
yeah yeah you were really really great
and you thank you but uh you guys will
know what scene I'm talking about when
you see it I think I know what senior
talking about
um all right I'm gonna go down the line
now more Cameron for you I'm dying to
know what it was like working with Sakai
I believe
your Dynamic together is just pitch
perfect electric adds so much energy to
the show at a perfect time what is it
like working together so that your
versions of the character feel like the
same people but also people who went
through different experiences okay first
off Sakai is amazing she's so cool uh
throughout filming we filmed for a while
together and we kind of found this like
big sister little sister Dynamic and I
think that made filming with her so much
easier because of that Bond and then as
a as far as finding the similarities in
older Tiff and younger Tiff we would
like meet up and we would work through
our scenes together before we would go
and film on set and we would find like
similarities that we could do to make it
look the same like we had to drink in
one scene that you probably know what
I'm talking about and uh there was a mug
and we were like okay we're gonna put
our thumb on top so it shows like Hey
we're both Tiff but we both look so
different and we both act in different
and we end up different so we just found
like similarities like that to implement
and she was just awesome to work with
she was so cool you crush it all right
Sophie I'll wrap with a question for you
Mack is just this super electric fiery
personality a really unique kind of vibe
in this show so for you even with all
your experiences there any particular
quality of hers that was something new
to you that you were really excited to
dig into I can't say I've played a a
character so abrasive and yet somehow
you you still I hope you still like her
so I would suggest that thank you I I
would say the comic books were an
excellent
blueprint as well as just in the script
she was so she was so beautifully
written so it was like a a lovely stream
that I could just follow beautifully
written you crush it bringing that to
life as do all of you congratulations on
paper girl thank you go watch this show
paper girls check it out